well in the world of YouTube there may
be no bigger star than bethany mota and
she's only 18 years old over the last
five years she has been building very
steadily her following on YouTube with
fashion and trend related videos to the
point where she now has six million plus
subscribers and a massive social media
following in general one of the way she
does it is by interacting with her fans
and doing meetups across the country
including at YouTube branecast event in
New York this week this is an event
where YouTube's really in a position to
talk about the YouTube stars and
comparing them to the world of
television getting advertisers on board
here's Jamie burn of YouTube we believe
that advertisers will always follow the
viewer today on YouTube we have more
people 18 to 34 years old then at cable
TV so with a lot of the things that we
talked about tonight with Google
preferred our new measurement solutions
with Nielsen and comscore and
introducing advertisers to our great
creators and our lineups are really
meant to help them buy YouTube
advertising easier